hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about how long
it takes to learn a language it's a
question i get all the time remember if
you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell to
get notifications and of course
by all means join me at link which is
where i learn languages so i get this
question quite often how long does it
take to learn languages in general
which is a very difficult question to
answer or how long does it take to learn
spanish or chinese
so
my first reaction is what's the hurry
and i'll explain why
now there are some evaluations by
authoritative uh
sources of information like the american
foreign services institute and i'll
leave a link in the description box and
you can look up how many instructional
hours they think is necessary or
based on their experience
is necessary for an english speaker to
learn different languages and you will
see there that obviously languages that
are closer to english that share
vocabulary with english
are easier
you know french spanish and so forth
even german
languages that are
more different from english take
significantly longer and there's an
indication there of how many hours
are required
now i have a few problems with that and
i'm going to go through those first
problem is
their value or their uh you know
estimate of how long it takes is based
on instructional hours
all of my experience in language
learning is that what you do outside the
classroom
is or can be
more important than what you do in the
classroom because
as manfred spitzer famously
said he got his book here
uh language learning takes place in our
brains not in the classroom so just
looking at instructional hours to me is
not a good indication of how long it
takes to learn a language so that's
point number one
point number two is
you know
to me language learning is a continuum
you know yes you start at a certain
point but you never finish
there is no language that i speak other
than english let's say where i don't
worry about mistakes that i make but
there is no
sort of second third fourth fifth
language that i speak as well as i would
like to speak it i make mistakes in all
of them
so but i enjoy them
so you know how long does it take to
achieve what becomes the question
and if you enjoy the process of language
learning as i do
does it really matter you will learn as
quickly as you learn
i think for example of my wife who
enjoys playing the piano she's been at
it for years i don't know 20 years she
learns on her own she enjoys it i hear
her music in the house i'm happy i enjoy
listening to it she's no concert pianist
she is slowly improving but the whole
process to her is enjoyable otherwise
she wouldn't do it
i'm much the same even in languages the
most recent languages that i'm learning
like persian and arabic
i've been at it now for quite a while
it's amazing it's two three years
um
i enjoy listening to those simple mini
stories and picking up
on something picking something out
noticing something that i hadn't noticed
before i enjoy the sensation of being
able to understand a podcast in arabic
or a story about
iranian cuisine in persian
but i'm a long way and i enjoy if i
happen to find a checkout person at the
supermarket who speaks arabic or persian
and i can speak to them in that language
i'm very happy but i'm enjoying the
whole process and i am still
a long way from being fluent
even that term fluent is a little bit
subjective because
some people
are motivated to want to speak
and to say even simple things even if
they don't understand what the other
person is saying
i enjoy
what i'm able to do in arabic and
persian which is listen to things read
things there aren't that many people
that i can speak to i'm not going to
spend
my evenings out you know looking for
people that i can inflict myself on to
so that i can practice my persian in
arabic so it depends also on what our
our goals are is in some discussion and
people who are involved in language
instruction we're talking about
interlanguage
which is a concept that language
teachers or
linguists of the academic variety have
come up with
and it sort of refers to the fact that
as we learn a language
you know when we begin we're we're very
much dominated by
our native language or a language we
know well and we gradually transition
into a situation where we more naturally
use the target language so while we're
in that transitional period
the the sort of academic
the teachers they talk about
interlanguage where the native language
is influencing the language that we're
trying to learn but that's almost always
the case there's nothing special about
that because the whole process of
learning a language is to gradually
transition
to a situation where you can naturally
think and naturally use the new language
i mean
i i have always done business with
non-native speakers of english they have
the trace of their native language so
germans say i have been living in
canada since many years which of course
is not correct english speakers speaking
french they have trouble even those who
speak very well they make mistakes in
gender for example or they'll make other
mistakes that reflect their native
language it was quite amusing to me
again i follow different people on
twitter
and there's one twitter account which
talks
which has something to do with modern
foreign language instruction in the uk
and apparently in the uk
for what they call the
gcse which is a general certificate for
secondary education
they have come up with a list of words
that someone should know
and different sort of intricacies of
grammar that people should be tested on
in order to get their
gcse certificate one of which was
jouer de and jouer
ah
in french when you play jouer
when you play an instrument
it's
piano when you play a sport
jouer
football whatever it's a okay
minor point so you're going to really
mark down a student who communicates
well who understands well because they
didn't touch on these specific grammar
points that some bureaucrat has decided
should be the criterion for
uh either passing someone or not passing
someone it's ridiculous
learning a language is a
continuum hopefully we can enjoy it
the objective is
comprehension to understand more and
more to acquire more and more words
to gradually get enough confidence in
the language so that we can have
meaningful conversations so but but if
people are looking for some kind of rule
of thumb
some kind of uh
you know
encouragement that is worth the effort
my experience has been that for
languages that are similar to ours with
the same writing system with a lot of
common vocabulary
and if we're motivated
whether we're in a classroom or learning
on our own
i think that in three months you can
make a breakthrough three months
on the other hand if we're dealing with
a language where
the writing system is different
in the case of say chinese or arabic or
hebrew or
you know korean very different
if there's essentially no common
vocabulary
then
to reach that sort of breakthrough point
where you feel now i've really achieved
something and i'm not talking about just
being able to say a few things you can
do that after a couple of days i'm
saying you have enough
of a sense now maybe you understand some
of the mini stories you have that
confidence i'm gonna make it
that can take six to nine months in
these more difficult languages and it
can seem at times as if we're not
getting anywhere and i can remember in
russian in czech now in arabic in
persian it seems that i'm forever
you know
treading water spinning my wheels and
yet that's not true if we continue with
the language
we eventually improve
and so that the key is to enjoy the
process to be satisfied with whatever
level you have achieved
now obviously if you have to pass the
gcse
then you know in addition to your
reading and listening and enjoyable
study of the language you may want to
get a hold of a list of the particular
points of grammar that they're going to
test you on or the particularly
particular vocabulary list the toefl
list but
by and large the learning pro and that's
specif only for the exam because when it
comes to learning the language in order
to be able to use the language to
communicate with people the key is not
to worry about how long does it take but
rather to find a way to enjoy the
language to engage with enjoyable
content to give yourself credit for what
you have achieved and simply stay with
it and you will continue to improve as
long as you continue doing those things